honoring the deceased it was exactly 30
years ago that fighting broke out here
in kochiri today the moldovan commune
lies in an enclave within the
pro-russian unrecognized breakaway state
called transnistria
what's happening in ukraine at the
moment
is deeply painful for us
and unsettling
30 years have passed but nothing has
changed
once again war has broken out this time
in nearby ukraine
only 20 kilometers from here
i heard it start in the morning
between 5 and 6 a.m i thought i heard
thunder
but not ordinary thunder
if there's thunder early in the year
temperatures will soon rise
that's what i thought to myself
but it wasn't thunder it was russian
bombs
yester river separates the republic of
moldova from russian controlled
transnistria in the east
the village of kocheri lies within this
territory
the only way to reach it is by ferry
russian soldiers guard the pier
[Music]
dw reported from the village back in
2015
at the time we were able to secretly
film russian troops stationed in the
area
these days that's too dangerous
kochiri locals told us not to risk it
we don't know what will happen next
what can i say
i heard the bombs the morning it all
started
it's terrible
municipal secretary evan mitchell has
just learned that one of the ukrainian
refugees who arrived is a local woman
who left 40 years ago when she married a
ukrainian now she's back seeking shelter
at her sister's place
my husband died three months ago
i had to leave both my sons behind in
ukraine
we speak on the phone
they tell me the shops are empty
you can't buy anything anywhere
they don't even have money for bread
and i can't do anything to help i i
don't know what will happen now
they're not allowed to leave ukraine
the village authorities are determined
to help however they can
it's clear we need to support her in
these times
[Music]
few of those who fled the war and tend
to stay here it's not far enough away
from the russian troops
most refugees first arrive in the
moldovan capital kisanau
so far over 200 000 refugees have fled
from ukraine to neighboring moldova its
reception centers are overcrowded per as
it is the country is taking in as many
refugees as possible ukrainians are
grateful even if most want to move on
is this any class they tend to us around
the clock
there's tea coffee bed linen
we'll head to romania first
i don't know where we'll go from there
[Music]
the people of kochiri meanwhile are
afraid their village could once again be
engulfed by war
a nightmare scenario one people here
hope can be averted